[Music]
foreign
everybody a cruel and nasty decision
that the reaction of Charities to the
government's big plan to tackle the
rising number of Channel Crossings
that's been revealed today the Home
Secretary pretty Patel making
arrangements to send Asylum Seekers
trying to reach Britain on small boats
to Rwanda for processing but what cost
to the taxpayer and will it put the
people's Smugglers off well we'll see as
the Secretary of State for Wales will be
telling us more about it very shortly
first let's take you through what we
know so far under the plan some Asylum
Seekers will travel four and a half
thousand miles to have their
applications processed in Rwanda the
refugee Council estimates that the plans
will cost 1.4 billion pounds a year
around 600 people cross the channel to
arrive in the UK yesterday alone and the
government says the daily figure could
rise to a thousand in just a few weeks
Sadia Chaudhary has the story for us
it is a drastic move it is also highly
controversial
the Prime Minister says our compassion
can be infinite but our capacity to help
people isn't
so today he's set to announce plans to
fly Asylum Seekers to Rwanda pretty
Patel will sign a partnership with the
East African state so that those
arriving to the UK illegally can be
relocated to Rwanda to rebuild their
lives there
this government says it has done more
than any other to resettle vulnerable
people through safe and legal roots it
says the new plans help Take Back
Control of our borders and fulfill the
outcome of the 2016 referendum but human
rights groups say the new measures are
cruel and that offshoring the UK's
Asylum system does nothing to address
the reasons why people take those
perilous Journeys in the first place
Amnesty International has labeled the
move appalling we've seen this policy
played out elsewhere in the world
Australia has pursued this it's a very
cruel policy that's done enormous harm
to people at huge costs to the
Australian taxpayer and being completely
ineffective
so knowing all of that it really Beggars
belief that our government is determined
to go ahead with this Charities say
offshore Asylum systems only add to
human suffering and Chaos at an
estimated cost they say of 1.4 billion
pounds Sadia Chaudhary Sky News
well shanky mariki is in Rwanda for us
this morning where the Home Secretary
Priti Patel is expected to set out
further details of a partnership with
the East African nation he's got the
latest
I think this is easily the most
controversial step the government has
taken to try and stem the flow of
migrants crossing the channel as part of
a multi-million pound deal which pretty
Patel will sign here in the capital of
Rwanda kagali we understand that Asylum
Seekers who arrive in the UK will
potentially be sent here more than 6 000
miles away to have those claims
processed those plans have already
attracted controversy though with human
rights groups saying that it is a cruel
idea and that it is also costly they're
estimating that it could be up to 1.4
billion pounds spent on this sort of
proposal pretty Patel the Home Secretary
will say that this is a chance for those
people who come here to rebuild their
lives we will find out more about those
proposals today
join this morning by the Secretary of
State for Wales Simon heart Mr Hart
thank you for joining us on the program
it's lovely to see you again let's talk
about that to start with should we
um why Rwanda
well I I think the first thing is we
have to deal with this problem we have a
very good relationship with random it's
a it's a it's an up-and-coming economy
it's got a very good record uh with
migrants in this particular issue and
it's a it's an arrangement which I think
suits both countries very well and
provides the best opportunities for
economic migrants for uh for those who
have been in the Forefront of this
particular
appalling problem for us so so long now
and I think that this Arrangement is a
really it has the potential uh to be a
really good step forward and a really
Humane step forward but the president of
Rwanda has been accused of Human Rights
abuses on more than one occasion
doesn't alter the fact that their
reputation uh as far as migrants
concerned and and their economic
progress is phenomenal so I don't think
we want to write this off now it is a
it's a scheme that we it's a start of a
scheme we want to work with the refugee
Council other charges try and make it
work but the but the fact is at the
moment the arrangement pretty well
everybody who observes what we see on
telly with uh the problem with the
channel and and the lives that have been
lost to the activities of the criminal
gangs which everybody accepts is not a
situation we can persist with in any
shape or form this has the potential I
think to be a really groundbreaking uh
Way Forward which provides a Humane
outcome for uh the victims in question
which is the most important priority
um and also make sure that we honor what
we're committed to do several years ago
which you've held us to encounter on
which is to resolve this problem as far
as the UK is concerned so you know so
this is the beginning of a process we
have to work with charitable the child
will start to get it to work okay but I
don't think I think would be wrong to
write it off but it is a country that
oversaw genocide of a million people in
a hundred days well in our lifetimes in
my son's lifetime absolutely but if we
adopt that attitude then we will never
be able to make progress with it Rwanda
is an improving economy with a good
human rights record now and a good
record as far as migrants are concerned
so it would be a natural fit as far as
this it's concerned Denmark are looking
at the a very similar scheme which I
know so it's not just us looking at
Rwanda as a potential partner in this
respect so I don't I think it would be
wrong simply to say what what you know
to to use the historical comparison as a
reason as a as a reason to just you know
abandon ship and and just not deal with
the problem we have to deal with this
problem so will those that we send to
Rwanda be subject to UK or Rwandan law
that's part of the announcement later on
today I'm not going to prejudge what the
homesick as we heard on that report home
second of PM are going to say later on
it's quite a complex it's quite a
complex memorandum of understanding
we're looking at I think the numbers for
last year were 28 000 people coming
across the channel attempting to come
across the channel vast majority of
those were economic migrants vast
majority of those were men those are the
those are the numbers we're looking at
some of the questions yes of course
otherwise we'll be here all day um are
there just men that we're sending second
are we just sending men yes I think
again I
don't feel about spelling out the detail
there are some sensitivities around that
but yeah the the vast majority of the of
the issues we're talking about will be
for male economic migrants okay and will
they be adult males yes okay how do we
determine somebody who doesn't have
papers whether they're an adult or not
well that's as I say that's what the
homesick is going to be spelling out
later on today so I I think yeah we we I
I think we just need to be careful I
mean it's tempting when they get to
Dover well they go straight to Heathrow
and straight on the on the plane or will
we process them again there has to be as
ever in in the conversations you and I
have had about this over the years
inevitably there is a bit of bureaucracy
around this to make sure that the
process is above all fair and a lot of
this is about fairness it's not about
sort of unnecessary bureaucracy it's
about fairness
in that will children be sent to Rwanda
no male no no no no I I keep going back
to the same comment I certainly need to
be a little bit careful about spelling
out each and every day but the principle
is no so this is about male economic
migrants uh in the main uh there is a
say different set of issues with women
and children and and refugees
what will happen to them well that's
that's going to be be much more akin to
what we do at the moment which is
looking after and safeguarding their
interests uh in the UK so that's that's
to a great extent pretty Patel will
expand a bit to a great extent that's
not going to alter massively but what we
are going to see well at the moment it
costs about 1.5 billion about 120
million pounds is the estimated cost of
this particular uh Arrangement but again
that's a FL that's a figure which will
alter depending on how whether the
scheme works on it because of course
part of this is about deterring the
criminal gangs as seeing the UK as a
destination which they can exploit or
exploit the people that they are sure
how it's trafficking
how does it deter the criminal gangs
well if they if they're not the ones
that being sent to Rwanda are they no
but the criminal the criminal gangs are
exploiting vulnerable people by
persuading by persuading them to part
with vast sums of money on some vague
promises that they get get them to the
to the UK where all of their dreams will
be uh fulfilled and that's where the the
exploitation is happening and uh we're
allowed to break up yeah okay so we have
to break up that business
I can understand what you're while
you're challenging Minister you do this
is a very lengthy answers exactly we
only have a limited amount of time
give me the details so are they not just
going to overload the votes with
vulnerable women precisely that is
precisely what this whole scheme is
designed to deter and that's precisely
precisely why we want to work with the
charitable sector with the refugee
council with others to ensure that that
does not happen that is exactly the
problem we have at the moment that is
why that is why we are tackling this
problem and I you know for years you
have rightly been holding us to account
about this you've rightly been telling
us that something needs to be done this
is something because this has taken nine
months of careful negotiation okay with
the Rwandan government this is going to
have the opportunity breaking up the
criminal gangs disincentivizing
exploitable people see safeguarding the
interest the safeguarding interests of
of people who have risked everything to
go on this journey that is that is what
this proposal is money is as good from a
woman as it is from a man
male economic migrants yeah but they'll
overload the boats with women then won't
they no no that's precisely well because
of the uh uh the the the process as it
is how do you know they won't well you
don't expect you you are suggesting that
that will be the case which is not in
anything
this is
designed how precisely the opposite
effect it is about breaking up criminal
gangs who so far have been able to
exploit vulnerable people in that
processing when they actually why are we
calling it processing when to go to
Rwanda to be processed when they're
never going to come back to the UK we're
exporting them aren't we which other
word would you choose to use
when we're trying to safeguard people's
interests we are trying to make sure
that actually the uh the the the manner
in which they have been previously
exploited comes down this is meant to be
about being being able to distinguish
between economic migrants refugees and
Asylum Seekers try to make sure that
people end up in a safe place with a
reasonable future that is something I
would imagine we could we could join in
some form of agreement okay where the
president's been accused of Human Rights
abuses let's move on to partygate last
time you were here you said that the
world had moved on from partygate it
doesn't look as though it has
um I don't think I've put it quite like
yeah you did that's exactly what you
said well I I I think I I said at the
time it probably wasn't actually the end
of the matter this is an ongoing live
play this is an ongoing live police
inquiry with the sudrey's report still
uh yet to be published so I I think
suggesting that the whole thing is over
it's probably misrepresenting uh what I
said at the time but the world has moved
on from party games well I think I I
think what I was just describing is the
attitude of my own constituency in West
Wales which were very clear about this
which they wanted an apology they wanted
Contrition they wanted some kind of
guarantee if one can provide that sort
of guarantee that this sort of thing
wouldn't happen again and I said I think
by substantial majority probably three
to one or four to one most people wanted
that outcome rather than necessarily
anybody involved with any of these
incidents to be uh to lose their job as
well and that people were and I believe
this to be the case rightly focusing on
the biggest humanitarian crisis in 1945
in Ukraine and I think I made the point
that I don't think on balance that it is
in the national interests or
International interests or Ukraine
interest to have a noisy and Loud
leadership contest
um whilst we're trying to to lead the
international response you trade that
happens to be okay my view it seems like
shared by majority Hugo suggesting
otherwise 75 say that the Prime Minister
knowingly lied and 55 among 2019
conservative voters say that uh he lied
and that he should go well I I you
wouldn't be surprised if I'm going to
describe that and let me just explain
why back in June 2020 Steve swinford
Steve swinford a colleague of yours
wrote a story in the times in which he
described that Downing Street Gathering
where Boris Johnson had a birthday cake
Richie sunach came into the room they
sang Happy Birthday the event for which
they have now both been fined at that
time written in the paper in June 2020
okay not a single person you the
metropolitan police opposition members
of parliament observers commentators the
news desk at the Times not a single
person at that time thought that that
was anything remarkable about that right
not a single one which makes Minister
come on he's been fined for going to the
party he's overseen 50
years of the law he's the first Prime
Minister in 300 years to be found guilty
of an offense but and he said if I may
because you do go on let just let me
finish my question if I may as a result
you know he's overseen the law being
broken 50 times he has lied to
Parliament
um do you think is it do you think
your suggestion that he lied to Paul or
deliberately large upon him
do you seriously think the dining Street
would have told Steve swinford well the
most experienced a journalists alone do
you seriously think they would have told
him about an event about an event in the
certain in the belief in the belief in
the belief that was that they were
bending the rules or they would
attempted to mislead Parliament it
subsequently turned out so are you
saying Parliament it's subsequently are
you saying he didn't mislead Parliament
because our understanding is that he's
going to go back to Parliament next week
to say I'm sorry if I misled you but I
did it by mistake so there is I mean I
know I know it always makes everybody
frustrated went and said oh there's a
difference between misleading and
deliberately mislead we had all of that
with Tony Blair in the Iraq War if you
remember the weapons of Masters we
didn't direct the law and the suggestion
was at the time the suggestion what the
at the time
is it it's that he had misled Parliament
that was the suggestion and the result
the argument was all around whether it
was so deliberate or whether it was
accidental but broke the law but the
fact do you think he is an honorable but
the fact is it would do you seriously
think let me ask the question if I can
do you say that's not how this works do
you seriously think so does anybody
seriously think that Downing Street
would have given a story about an event
in the cabinet room which is
do you think do you think that they
would would have done that if they
thought that event or any in the
immediation quite possibly did that it
would have been yes I do you so do you
think that they would have actually done
that too yeah and then that qualifies as
some kind of deliberate attempt to flag
that and why didn't at the time then if
that was the case and this story
don't know where I'm going because when
that story was published not a single
person put their hand up and said that
is a breach of covered it's become
apparent that the Prime Minister has
overseen 50 breaches of the law being
broken into I don't know where you've
got 50 from but I I because 50 uh
notices have already been issued so 50
times somebody has broken uh the law in
Downing Street
you know more that you know more about
this and me uh it was a statement from
the Metropolitan Police
well as I say you know more about this
man I'm not going to expect but we can't
seriously we can't speculate about it
you tempted me last week and I probably
went too far in the sort of speculation
state but we can't speculate about uh uh
an inquiry which is incomplete you would
be the first to criticize me if we were
trying to second guess what the outcome
is asking you about 50 times when the
law has been broken that this prime
minister's overseas and you'd still
think it's but I'll tell you what I took
it all right
can I repeat what I said last week which
is it you know nobody's I I literally I
don't want to excuse or Justify and I
mean I am a sort of appalled by all of
this as anybody else it's not about
trying to say that this was all fine or
didn't happen actually you know we've
all had I mean I'm a member of the
government I have to take my fair show
that claim on this we all have to hold
our hands up yes it was a misjudgment
yes I wish dearly that it could have
been uh could have all been done
differently but the fact is that it
wasn't and I fact it you asked my
opinion my opinion is but people who get
a fixed penalty nature should not
automatically just because they're in
public life also expect to be sacked at
the same time that is my view it's
probably on the more liberal end of the
scale but that is my view okay one
wonders what will happen if he gets more
than one I'm sure you'll come back and
talk to us but we are massively get me
in trouble yeah look forward to seeing
you very soon thank you Minister thanks
a lot enjoy Easter thank you thank you
looking at what the papers are saying
this morning the telegraph leading with
the government's plans to send channel
migrants to Rwanda to have their Asylum
claims processed the eye says pretty
Patel's deal with uh export Britain's
Asylum Seekers while the male says it's
a dramatic blueprint designed to smash
the people smuggling gangs in the
channel the Metro leads with the
resignation of the Justice Minister Lord
Wolfson over Boris Johnson's refusal to
resign after being fined for attending
illegal dining Street parties during
lockdown and the guardian is also
focused on partygate and says that Mr
Johnson could face three more fine lines
over events he's alleged to have
attended and the financial times says
the Potential Threat from neighboring
Russia has pushed Finland and Sweden
closer towards joining NATO
Russia says their Flagship in the Black
Sea the Moscow missile Cruiser has
suffered serious damage after a fire on
board the Ukrainian governor of the
Odessa region said two missiles had
struck the ship Russia though claims a
fire detonated ammunition on board
saying the causes were being established
elsewhere in the conflict Russia says
it's taken control of mariopol after
more than a thousand Ukrainian troops
surrendered but Ukrainian officials deny
the claim saying the battle for the city
is ongoing
and U.S President Joe Biden has approved
800 million dollars in new military
assistance to Ukraine including weapons
and additional helicopters
while the Russian defense Ministry says
the 500 crew on board the Moscow were
saved Mark stone is standing by for us
in central Ukraine right now um there is
hello to you mark what more do we know
about what's going on in Mario Paul and
also with the ship
good morning K from donipro here in
eastern Ukraine let me tell you first of
all about this announcement by Joe Biden
overnight the U.S president
announcing 800 million dollars worth of
new equipment this is a very very
significant announcement from the
Ukrainian perspective it's come very
late in the day but the shopping list of
weapons and equipment that the Americans
now say delivered to the ukrainians is
quite astonishing just looking down it
they are talking about among other
things 300 drones 10 anti-artillery
radar 500 Javelin missiles and then even
more significantly 200 armored personnel
carriers a hundred Humvees these Jeeps
that the Americans have used for so many
years and most significantly of all 17
helicopters as well now um all of this
is something that the Ukrainian
government has been asking for for some
time the American president says that
this equipment will be tailored for what
is expected to happen next which is the
battle for Don Bass this Eastern
Ukrainian region where it is expected
that a massive Russian troops will soon
begin their push on eastern Ukraine
remember they've moved out of the region
of Kiev and other areas they've
regrouped under a new Commander a man
who is a veteran of the wars in chechnya
and and Syria as well they've regrouped
the command structure has changed and
the expectation is they will move in
over eastern Ukraine in the coming days
in terms of that ship the Moscow it's
one of the flagships of the Russian
Fleet the ukrainians have told us two
Ukrainian sources have told us it was
hit by two Ukrainian missiles in the
Black Sea overnight the Russians have
not admitted that but they say it is on
fire and all 500 troops that have been
evacuated I think the focus now will be
mariopol the Russians say it will fall
within hours the ukrainians say they are
still fighting there and the number from
the mayor of the the mayor says that the
number to have died in the past six
weeks an extraordinary 21
000 people
okay thank you
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you and Jersey has
announced its freezing assets connected
to the Russian oligarch Roman Abramovich
worth an estimated 5 billion pounds
officials on the island also said police
should search properties believed to be
linked to the billionaire but didn't
give any further detail
from today high-end art and super Yachts
can no longer be sold to Russia by
companies in the UK the ban on exporting
luxury goods is part of a new set of
sanctions aimed at hurting the Russian
economy as the Kremlin continues its
invasion of Ukraine but there's some
skepticism over how impactful the ban
will be
if as I understand it the ban is just on
luxury goods entering Russia
um I think it'll be fairly
you should it'll be a fairly useless
um band because they will simply buy the
goods for other homes around the world
taking action ourselves isn't the only
thing we need to do leadership on the
world stage is also about speaking to
other countries persuading other
countries to introduce similar measures
as well and that's what the government
has to continue to do
police in New York have arrested and
charged a man with a terrorism offense
in connection with a shooting on a
subway train 10 people were shot and
wounded when a gunman set off smoke
grenades before firing 33 shots with a
handgun 62 year old Frank James was
taken into custody after a 30-hour
Manhunt officials say he called the
police himself
staying in the U.S the jury in the trial
of a british-born member of the ISIS
group that came to be known as The
Beatles has retired to consider its
verdict El sheffy al-shake is accused of
Hostage taking resulting in death and
other crimes four Americans were killed
by the group and videos of their
killings made public
body cam footage has been released by
police in Michigan showing an officer
fatally shooting a black man following a
struggle during a traffic stop Patrick
lawyer 26 was killed outside a house in
Grand Rapids State Police are
investigating the incident David Blevins
has this report
hey stay in the car
stay in the car
in the car it began as a routine traffic
stop dude I'm stopping you police pulled
Patrick Loyola over because the license
plate didn't match the car you have a
license
do you have a license
who would I'm stopping you do you have a
license
he appeared to be retrieving his driving
license before a struggle ensued
1950. he's got one on it big officer
wrestling with him on the ground
he was lying on the suspect's back
apparently fighting for control of the
taser when the Fatal shot was fired
everyone
foreign
police said he had died when an
officer's gum discharged but his family
and friends say he was killed execution
Style
Patrick Loyola a Congolese Refugee was a
father of two young children one aged
two the other just three months his
family has hired civil rights attorney
Benjamin Crump who represents the family
of George Floyd and other high-profile
victims he wants the officer charged
police said he'd been placed on paired
Leaf while they conducted a criminal
investigation we felt that I'm balance
it was more important to be transparent
with the community to provide one
information the Grand Rapids police
department has immediately before that
process is finished
[Music]
the release of the police videos has
already sparked protests in Grand Rapids
Michigan demonstrators demanding Justice
for the victim for many his death
suggests that the police reform promised
in the wake of George Floyd's murder has
not materialized David Blevins Sky News
Washington
in other news for you on the program
this morning there's a vacancy coming up
at the top of the Metropolitan Police
Force you may have heard applications
open for crested Dick's replacement
yesterday with candidates tasked with
making the force
more professional
if you can offer inspirational and
empowering leadership the position
offers a 293
000 pound salary I'll say that again 293
000 pounds
wow now under my eyes watering this
morning now there's concern China's
manufacturing delays due to their covid
lockdown in Shanghai and jillin will
have a ripple effect on the cost of
living in the UK many of China's largest
manufacturing hubs have been forced to
close following a covet outbreak in
their two major cities Tom's been on
this story for us throughout live from
Beijing he's with us again now hi Tom
what's the latest morning
morning Kevin the latest here is that
covered infections are still Rising a
new record of 29 000 cases and that
might not sound like very much it's
certainly less than there is in the UK
at the moment the problem in terms of
the global supply chain is China's
response to that Shanghai 25 million
people under lockdown and their various
restrictions across the country that
means there have been closures or
suspensions of factory we've seen
pegatron which makes components for
iPhones that's closed its Factory Tesla
closed a factory as well there's also
concern about what's happening at the
Port it's a very important port in
Shanghai it's usually a very busy port
and it has been under closed loop
management that's a sort of Chinese word
for trying to seal it off from the rest
of the country and keep things operating
the problem though is that you need
trucks going in and out of that port to
take those containers off to bring Goods
to ship them out and that's where we're
starting to see all sorts of trouble
really and this isn't just in Shanghai
there's lots of covered restrictions
around the country we're speaking to
trucks uh Lorry drivers in Beijing doing
yesterday they're saying how difficult
it is now to enter cities to live those
good that means components aren't going
from Factory to factory and a lot of the
time you just need one component not to
be there for it to have an impact now if
it continues like this uh the the impact
so far on inflation on the cost of
living has been minimal but if this
spreads if it hits Guangzhou in the
South and we have seen some cases there
other cities like sujo and other
important port city it could have a
massive effect on Supply chains which is
why businesses here have been calling on
China to soften its Dynamic zero covered
policy to try and make these things run
a bit smoother China is not going to do
that it says without the dynamic zero
covered policy uh China would be
overwhelmed with covid-19 and the supply
chain crisis would get even worse but I
think it's going to be a tough few weeks
and months for households around the
world okay look at this is it a bird is
it a plane
no it's a comet in fact it's the largest
Comet ever seen by astronauts its
diameter is about can you guess from
those pictures it's about 80 miles
apparently and its mass is thought to be
around 500 trillion tons that's a
hundred thousand times greater than the
mass of a typical Comet it was first
spotted in 2010 and NASA says it's
hurtling towards Earth at around 22 000
miles an hour don't look up I was my
director Stewart just said that I was
just about to say I hate it when he
beats me but don't worry it'll never get
closer than one billion miles away from
the Sun and that won't be for another
nine years
uh let's take a look at some of the best
pictures making the morning's paper
should we the son has this picture of a
common household mop also it seems look
a little closer and it's a Hungarian
pulley dog sporting a huge mass of
dreadlocks as it has fun on a day out
look at him he looks great and the
express shows us this shot of a rare
Beauty one of the last Spitfires in the
world restored to its original
magnificence taking to the skies
gorgeous and Chewie is taking a break
from the Millennium Falcon to ride some
waves
at Scarborough looking like he knows
what he's doing clearly he's no
Wookie
thank you our top story is for you this
morning here on Sky News the government
is due to enhanced plans to send Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda in an effort to stop
Channel Crossings
mixed messages after an explosion
damages a Russian Flagship Ukraine says
two missiles hit but Russia claims it
was an ammunition explosion on the ship
conservative peer David Wilson has quit
as Justice Minister over the prime
minister's breach of covert regulations
well the Secretary of State for Wales
has told this program that Rwanda has a
good record on human rights in defensive
plans to send Asylum Seekers there Simon
Hart said it would be wrong to only look
at rwanda's history when considering it
as a partner
Rwanda is an improving economy with a
good human rights record now and a good
record as far as migrants are concerned
so it would be a natural fit as far as
it's concerned Denmark are looking at a
very similar scheme which I know so it's
not just us looking at Rwanda as a
potential partner in this respect so I
don't I think it would be wrong simply
to say what what you know to to use the
historical comparison as a reason as a
reason to just you know abandon ship and
and just not deal with the problem we
have to deal with this problem
and our political correspondent Joe Pike
is standing by for us from home actually
this morning hope you're feeling a bit
better Joe
um what did you make of what the
minister had to say
well certainly UK his claim that Rwanda
has a good human rights record I think
is debatable certainly Human Rights
Watch themselves uh say arbitrary
detention ill treatment and torture in
official and unofficial detention
facilities is commonplace and high
profile critics have been arrested or
threatened the government's view though
here seems to be that the situation is
not working certainly uh just yesterday
it's 600 people arrived in the UK on
small boats and if you speak to people
in the home office I have done it in the
last few months they keep on talking
about getting rid of of pool factors
this well partly they believe get rid of
those pool factors and also provide a
deterrent to The Gangs the criminal
gangs that profit from all of this yes
that has already been a backlash from
human rights groups who say it is cruel
or despicable opposition parties like
the SMP saying this is evil and chilling
I think that's really what the
government would have expected what they
believe is that a lot of their voters
and supporters especially those who
voted for brexit do think the
immigration system in this in this
country needs to be changed it needs to
be developed but it needs to be fixed
and part of that is uh doing uh this and
and taking some people to Rwanda men of
course
only okay thank you thanks a lot Joe
Maddie's standing by for us in Dover
this morning over the place for us this
week on The Breakfast show she's in
Dover this morning hello to
um Maddie so we're going to be hearing
more about what's going to happen to
male migrants who come across the
channel seeking asylum in the UK there
were an awful lot yesterday weren't
there
yes good morning Kate as you can see
it's it's a lovely day here in Dover the
sun is shining and the Sea behind me is
calm and flat and that normally means
you get more people trying to cross
across the channel because those
conditions which can be so dangerous and
inhospitable they're a bit easier to
make the crossing we think that Boris
Johnson will confirm later today that
600 people manage to cross the channel
yesterday that means we're on track for
a record year in terms of Small Boat
Crossings
um it takes us we think to more than 5
000 uh people this so far this year to
put that in context last year we didn't
reach that figure till June last year
was a record year for migrant Crossings
in the channel this year it could be
even higher so this is exactly why Boris
Johnson will argue they are trying to
introduce this policy
um I don't know what's going on with
that bird we can hear a bird chirping
very loudly while you're talking to his
money you're obviously in a very lovely
part of the world today
yeah it certainly looks it thanks and
sounds it thanks very much indeed thank
you
I think it sounded like something from
Central Casting didn't it now let's go
back to those uh government plans to fly
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda in an attempt
to stop Channel Crossings uh joined by
Amnesty International UK's Refugee and
migrant rights director Steve Valdez
Simons hello to you Steve thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
what do you make of this idea
oh it's truly shocking
um we have years of evidence from
Australia about precisely this policy
measure which has done nothing to stop
people coming to Australia seeking
Asylum has inflicted a huge amount of
Cruelty on a relatively small number of
people basically imprisoned for years
and years on islands in the South
Pacific and all at enormous costs to the
Australian taxpayer such that Australia
has for some years now been busy trying
to shut the whole thing down why on
Earth this government thinks that we
need to adopt some measure like this is
beyond belief
what's the alternative
well the alternative frankly is
recognizing that this country still
receives very few people seeking Asylum
compared to even its close European
neighbors let alone poorer countries
elsewhere around the world and if we
were to put our efforts into making our
Asylum system function as it's supposed
to in determining people's claims the
people who arrive here then we could
deal with this a lot more effectively
efficiently and indeed humanely which
would be to the benefit of all concerns
and as for the issue of people crossing
the boats in the in the channel why on
Earth do we not identify people in
northern France particularly those with
connections here and provide them a safe
journey here rather than keep allowing
Smugglers to profit from our miserable
policies that compel people to make
these Journeys because they have nothing
else on offer for them
because I suppose the response from the
government would be um people Smugglers
who make a fortune out of taking people
across the channel in unseaworthy
vessels many of them it has to be said
um so they don't know who these people
are they don't make themselves known in
uh in France before they make the
crossing
well it's undoubtedly true that it's
very difficult to tackle
um the smuggling business but one thing
that every every
um expert of any description will tell
you and has been telling the government
and others for years is that if you want
to make any serious inroad into this you
have to take away their business and you
don't take away their business by making
things more miserable and difficult that
just empowers them that's why they they
make this money in the first place
because there aren't roots for these
people safe ones so why on Earth keep on
with the same sorts of policies of
simply trying to deter prevent and
punish people who were just driven
further and further into the hands of
people who exploit them
okay
um I'm afraid we must leave it there but
um it's uh very good of you to take the
time to join us this morning thank you
thank you
let's talk about the NHS As It prepares
to publish an update on the backlog in
Care New figures show some people have
been waiting years for treatment the PA
news agency asked NHS England trusts how
many patients had been waiting for three
and four years in January from the 69
that replied more than 91 patients have
been waiting for at least three years
with at least eight waiting for more
than four
20 are the longest waiters required
trauma and orthopedic surgery these
include those who need hip and knee
Replacements joined now by the chief
executive of the NHS Confederation
Matthew Taylor hello to Mr Taylor thank
you for joining us people in pain and
needing the services of the NHS having
to wait years when's it going to get
better
well there's nothing that we would like
to do more in the NHS than to make
inroads into this backlog and indeed
what you've seen in recent months is
very high activity levels in the NHS the
problem is that we have still got covert
um and that makes a significant impact
on what we can do uh in the Health
Service so we have 16 000 people with
covert in hospitals uh in England
um and that puts pressure on a system
which is always you know always working
flat out that's the nature of our Health
Service we have fewer beds ahead of
population than similar countries fewer
nurses doctors so we're always using our
resources at full stretch and then if
you add in
uh this covid Spike um then it becomes
very difficult what I think we're likely
to see today in the statistics
is some uh increase in elective activity
but also huge problems in terms of
accidents and emergency
ambulance times the time it takes to get
people from ambulances into hospitals
and also a huge issue about people in
hospital who are actually ready to leave
but can't leave because our social care
system is essentially falling apart
so you know we really want to reduce
those numbers of people waiting uh
people in the NHS are acutely aware of
the impact that could have on people but
what we need is we need fewer people
with covid we need these covered
pressures to decline and we need urgent
action in relation to social care
because actually although I speak for
that for the Health Service most of the
leaders I speak to would say that it was
actually social care that is the number
one priority for Action right now
um do you feel that the living with
covid plan uh put forward by the
government is helping or hindering the
NHS
you know I'm not sure we have a living
with Kobe plan I think we have a living
without restrictions and I think a
living with Kobe plan would mean that
first of all you would recognize that we
uh still have covert out there that we
are still seeing people either we are
still seeing many people in hospital now
a lot of the people in hospital covid
didn't go in with covert but if they
develop covered first of all we have to
ensure that they don't pass on to other
people but secondly if you have covered
you can then get that combined with
other problems so honestly obviously by
their nature people in hospital are
vulnerable so if you add in code that
can increase their vulnerability and
then there's the issue of Staff absence
so staff absence has gone back up as a
consequence of members of Staff having
covered so we do need a proper plan and
that plan would involve first of all
clear messaging to the public you know I
travel around London and I've seen mask
wearing go from just about everyone
wearing masks to getting mixed to the
point at which now uh certainly in the
last few days very few people I have
seen London underground or whether or
wearing masks there are still things
that we can do we need a clear message
about how we use the Health Service I
was speaking to a Health Service leader
in the south of England just yesterday
who's put in place their own social
media campaign to encourage people to
use the GP to use 111 to use the
community pharmacist to not use accident
emergency because the pressure's there
are so in are so intense and we need
reassurance that as long as these covert
pressures are there that the funding and
support for the NHS will recognize that
and that when it comes to setting
targets for us they've got to be
realistic in view of the pressures that
we're dealing with
foreign
people I think um are just looking at
those figures 20 odd thousand people 23
778 people to be precise in England
waiting more than two years to start
routine hospital treatment what's your
message to them this morning
uh the message is that NHS leaders I
speak to uh leaders every day are doing
everything they can it's a matter of you
know of of ethical commitment of Pride
for NHS leaders that they can reduce
this to your these two year elevators
the target is to do it by uh July that
is still a Target that people are aiming
for uh but I would uh say to your
viewers please even though we're not
talking about covered even though the
government seems determined not to talk
about what's going on in the Health
Service right now you know things are
very difficult for us because of the
pressures of kovid because of the amount
of demand that has has built up so we
will do everything uh to clear that to
your group group but don't forget people
are always adding to that so every time
you get rid of a group of people you
give them an operation there's a
procedure we don't have them waiting for
two years there's another group of
people who've been waiting a year and 10
months or 11 months so that that that
that that group is going to replenishing
itself so we have to work very hard to
try to meet the target of not having
anybody waited two years but you know in
the end we would want people not waiting
one year not waiting six months and yeah
you know that's a medium-term process
and critical to that is going to be
Workforce you know we have a hundred and
ten thousand vacancies uh in the Health
Service we desperately need a plan uh to
bring in the workforce that we need in
order that we can get back to the
position we were in just a few years ago
we're actually waiting this were not a
huge issue in the Health Service okay uh
we must leave it there but thank you
very much indeed for taking the time to
join us this morning thank you
let's take you to the U.S should we wear
Johnny Depp is suing his ex-wife Amber
Heard for libel you may have heard on
the second day of the trial one of
Depp's friends told the court that
herd's domestic violence claim is
fraudulent
it's not fair it's not right what what
she did and what happened for so many
people to get affected from this it's I
it's insane
well joining us oh actually earlier in
the day I should say lawyers for her
continued their cross-examination of
Depp's older sister Christy dembrowski
who first took to the stand on Tuesday
she was asked to confirm an email
exchange she had with a doctor who
helped debt with his addiction to
Painted medication she said she was
concerned about Depp's use of one
medication but didn't believe he had a
problem with drugs or alcohol overall
Scotty L Hughes a friend of the program
is with us now hi Scotty so this is the
sequel to what we saw in a court in
London give us the context
oh absolutely good morning Kate you know
in a trial that's actually more than
just about two celebrities going through
a bitter divorce in all of the
proceedings this has actually turned out
to be a trial about whether a man can be
treated fairly not only in the court of
public opinion but in an American court
of law now as you said at the end of a
day or two in this defamation trial in
Fairfax Virginia between Johnny Depp and
his former wife Amber Heard the jury did
hear from the older sister who testified
about the physical and emotional abuse
that their mother had given them and
Johnny's commitment to never causing
that to someone else Johnny Depp's
lawyers also said in the four to five
Decades of relationships that Mr deput
had he had never ever been accused
before of ever hurting someone and yet
in comparison to the 2009 arrest of
heard for domestic violence against at
that time her ex-wife her lawyers also
encountered by pointing out the majority
of the 14 times the herd State she was a
victim of abuse by depth was when he was
high or when he was drunk two habits
that were confirmed in text and emails
between deaf and a sister now okay the
real emotion of the day actually came as
you point out from from his friend close
friend of over 42 years where he said
heard had created a malicious lie which
hurt many he said that even though he
looked at for marks of abuse he never
saw them on the actress but he did
confirm there was a very violent text
that was that depth had sent him saying
he hoped the actresses rotting a corpse
was a decomposing in the bleeping trunk
of a Honda Civic now okay the big part
in this what happens next is several
celebrities are possibly rumored to be
pulled into this as a future Witnesses
including Elon Musk which was the first
relationship that Amber Heard had
following filing for divorce and other
celebrities who might be called to
testify on the relationship this case
however is different from the case that
you saw over on you UK that was against
the sun mainly because it was against a
publication and it was thrown out but in
this case the judge in Fairfax Virginia
said that the trial can proceed and it
was it's expected to last around at six
weeks
okay let's go to now he's thank you
as far as Rwanda is concerned what do
you know about that East African country
um I've traveled there uh previously and
um it's uh it was a place of genocide in
the 1990s human rights abuses and claims
against the president Linger on
nevertheless the decision by the Home
Secretary and thus the prime minister is
to send those migrants that are crossing
the channel to Rwanda to be processed we
believe that is just going to be men at
this stage
um but we put it to the Wales secretary
this morning how appropriate it is to
send somebody who is trying to seek
refuge in the UK to a country with human
rights abuses
Rwanda is an improving economy with a
good human rights record now and a good
record as far as migrants are concerned
so it would be a natural fit as far as
it's concerned Denmark are looking at a
very similar scheme which I know so it's
not just us looking at Rwanda as a
potential partner in this respect so I
don't I think it would be wrong simply
to say what what you know to to use the
historical comparison as a reason as a
as a reason to just you know abandon
ship and and just not deal with the
problem we have to deal with this
problem
foreign
actually I've not got the figure to hand
uh came over at the channel yesterday
because the weather is getting um an
awful lot better and as you can see
brought in to Dover uh we'll be there to
bring you the very latest in just a
couple of minutes times here on the
program just want to grab my phone and
update you a little bit further as far
as Human Rights Watch is um concerned
they've given us more information within
the last few moments so let me see if I
can access that for you and they are
saying in response to that interview
that we did the proposal shows the Stark
difference between the rhetoric and
reality of a British government that is
abandoning its responsibility to people
fleeing conflict and persecution UK
government has a legal and moral duty to
provide Sanctuary we know from Australia
that offshore processing simply doesn't
work this proposal is inhumane unethical
and cruel if it designs solely as a
deterrent and to signal to refugees that
they are no longer welcome so what did
the Wales secretary have to say we'll
have more on that coming up in the next
hour of the program also coming up we
are going to be talking to labor what do
they think about what should happen next
as far as refugees migrants coming to
the UK are concerned and also party gate
we put that to the Wales Minister again
this morning to ask him he said last
time he was on the show the world had
moved on from partygate got that one
wrong didn't he what does labor think
about that as well and a little bit
later on we're going to be talking to a
young lad who is climbing a very big
mountain to raise money for somebody who
was injured in the Manchester Arena
attack all of that to come throughout
the course of the next two hours here on
the program if you've only just joined
us where have you been I'll see you at
the top of the hour
foreign